[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver si
nous nous connaissons déjà et si vous
êtes des couche-tôt du samedi soir et
bien sachez que je me nomme bouvard que
je me prénomme philippe et que je suis
le producteur et le présentateur de
cette nouvelle série d'émissions
quotidiennes que nous avons intitulé
passé dont me voir alors suivez le guide
s'il vous plaît je vais vous faire
visiter ce décor que nous avons
construit à votre intention est donc
essuyé les plâtres on rassurez vous ils
seront beaucoup moins mouillé que ceux
du palm beach à cannes de sinistre
mémoire ça c'est le rôle par lequel vous
l'avez vu on entre directement de la rue
iman beaucoup de choses à ce dispositif
mais nous allons le meublé peu à peu
pour que vous ayez une surprise chaque
jour voici la vaillante équipe grâce à
laquelle cette émission pourra avoir
lieu
ninon monty qui doublera alexandre
tartas dans la réalisation de cette
émission paul wermus mon fidèle adjoint
christiane nicoli ni astrid de
t'serclaes patricia balme et martine
lemoine
vous connaissez tous le monde ou presque
alors maintenant le décor d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas un décor c'est un lieu de
travail que nous avons voulu fonctionnel
aussi variés que possible puisque nous
sommes destinés à l'habiter pendant près
de dix mois
cinq fois par semaine à la dame que vous
voyez de dos et volontaire c'est pour
que vous ayez tout à l'heure une petite
surprise
ça c'est le coin bureau dans ce coin
nous traiterons des problèmes sérieux il
y en aura il ya un piano à toutes fins
utiles et puis il y à un coin salon où
je reçois d'autres invités ça ne veut
pas dire d'ailleurs que ce soit pas des
invités sérieux mais enfin on pourra
évoquer des sujets plus bas tu as alors
je me réjouis que ce premier invité soit
charles aznavour parce que en consultant
mes petites archives personnelles je me
suis avisé que chaque fois que nous
avions commencé nouvelle série télévisée
eh eh bien vous étiez là j'étais là
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais attention ça
n'est pas charles aznavour le chanteur
que j'ai invités aujourd'hui sont bien
là comme il en existe un il y en a un
bien sûr au c'est un personnage à
facettes il ya un charles aznavour
compositeur qui ça n'est pas lui non
plus ne suis pas docteur non plus c'est
pas l'auteur c'est le charles aznavour
comédien et comédien le cinéma s'est
jamais fait de théâtre au il ya
tellement longtemps qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas en parler alors cinéma parce qu'on
va vous revoir dans ce film que l'on a
primé au dernier festival de cannes le
tambour n'est pas le principal rôle non
j'ai ce qu'on appelle en anglais un
caméo oui ça te dirait un rôle est un
rôle court d'excusés on y meurt vite je
pouvais pas continuer alors on a
l'impression quand on regarde les films
que vous faites maintenant trop peu
d'ailleurs à notre gré que vous cherchez
- le grand rôle que le moyen rôle bien
typés assez marquants dont je prends ce
qu'on me donne et qui peuvent satisfaire
si on me donnait un grand rôle qui me
plaisait je le prendrais je peux vous
dire qu'on n'en propose pas 160000 par
semaine on propose un de temps en temps
ils sont pas satisfaisants alors
j'accepte celui qui me semble le plus
proche de ce que je veux faire alors
généralement c'est un rôle des migrants
parfois
hydrelis souvent mais suivant souvent
les rails souvent à quoi ça tient selon
je pense que je prends bien l'accent je
crois oui
puis je ressemble un petit peu dans nos
têtes oui c'est vrai j'ai toujours l'air
de décembre de l'exodus je descends
toujours d'un avion je venu pour vous
donne directement l'aéroport et
finalement on est aussi étonné de vous
voir dans des films qui sont plutôt
produits à l'étranger qu'en france
oui je sais pas au nom non j'étais
vergobbi ya pas tellement longtemps
c'était un film produit en france
alors vous reviendrez quand même en
france poussé la chansonnette de temps
en temps régulièrement
oui n'ont jamais manqué au rendez vous
olympia par exemple un bien sûrement au
par exemple bon cette chansonnette vous
la poussez heureusement pour vous aussi
à l'étranger
oui dans quelle mesure la poussée vous
en français je chante à peu près bon
dans la dernière tournée j'ai fait aux
états unis là je chantais sur 27
chansons je chantais huit chansons
françaises mais ce qui est important
c'est que la chanson soit française qui
est important c'est que la chanson
française soient traduites quand on sait
le nombre de gens sont étrangers à qui
sont traduites en français
il vaut mieux que la chanson voyage dans
la langue du pays plutôt qu'elle ne soit
pas chanter même en français est ce que
vous voulez dire que vous êtes un
défenseur de la langue française à
l'étranger
c'est un défenseur de la chanson
française à l'étranger de ce fait je
pense que quand ils entendent la chanson
en anglais on dit c'est que c'est une
chanson française ça donne souvent le
goût aux gens d'acheter le disque ou le
format en français et se familiariser de
se familiariser avec la langue
vous vivez en ce moment en suisse pense
que c'est provisoire et qu'un jour vous
viendrez vous ré installer ici tout est
possible alors défenseur de la langue
française c'est très bien vous allez
pouvoir le montrer puisque vous êtes
aussi écrivain à vos heures et des
heures qu'ils ne sont pas tout perdu
c'est un livre de nouvelles
oui j'ai créé un gars de l'an le bas en
franglais en anglais en anglais et en
français
oui c'était à lille il ya des choses que
je juge écrit directement en anglais les
choses que j'ai créés directement en
troisième mais le livre sera
définitivement retouchée et traduits
normalement parce que la langue ne la
possède pas suffisamment et puis le
second tome de vos mémoires
c'est un homme différent qui vit qui est
sorti nom qui sort aujourd'hui en
angleterre en anglais en anglais
toujours dans le cadre de la défense de
la langue française
écoutez c'est la chanson française et
puis c'est d'ailleurs dans le livre en
anglais il y à des textes de mes
chansons qui sont gratuites d'idir
allemand s'était drogué la plupart du
temps c'est une adaptation parce qu'il
faut traduire en rimes en donné que dans
les chansons sont traduites normalement
il ya des phrases qui échappent dans la
chance dans la traduction chante et qui
ne peuvent pas échapper dans la
traduction écrite des au moment où on
fait l'europe ne pas vous chicaner là
dessus c'est d'autant moins d'ailleurs
que vous savez qu'on imite toujours les
mêmes et vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir qui sont les mêmes artistes
toujours les mêmes politiciens
or j'ai réussi à trouver une nouvelle
limitation c'est quand même assez rare
c'est chantal le gallia qui fait chaque
soir les beaux soirs de du rive droite
un nouveau cabaret parisien qui a eu la
première l'idée de s'attaquer à
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
impopulaire en france surtout si l'on en
croit les sondages et ce quelqu'un c'est
simone veil ce que je vais vous dire est
fondamentalement important récemment
j'ai eu la désagréable surprise pourquoi
désagréable et bien d'abord parce
qu'elle est désagréable deuxièmement
parce que les lois ne pas l'être
la désagréable surprise de constater une
recrudescence des viols et autres
plaisirs en tout genre en europe et plus
particulièrement dans ma propre rue rue
de la baudruche personnellement en ce
qui me concerne moi même et par
quelqu'un d'autre
je m'intéresserai aux problèmes qui me
touche de près c'est à dire l'europe
personnellement je trouve ma démarche
astucieuse pourquoi elle est astucieuse
et bien d'abord parce qu'elle est
astucieuse
deuxièmement parce qu'elle est loin
d'être idiote c'est mon avis et je le
partage
et pour conclure je dirai pourquoi je
dirais bien parce qu'il faut dire
pour éviter de se taire
je dirais qu'ils veulent trop prouver ne
prouve rien voilà limitation avec tout
ce que ça comporte de caricature bien
sûr jacques tôt j'ai appris voici
quelques heures officiellement
concrètement ses nouvelles fonctions
d'administrateur général de la
comédie-française n'aviez jamais vu
d'ailleurs avoué le un administrateur
général du premier de nos subventionnés
qui ait l'air aussi jeune est ce que
votre vie a changé est ce que les gens
sont différents à votre égard depuis que
vous occuper ce poste ne sont pas tous
rentrés la comédie française a ouvert
cette porte bien sûr mais le spectacle
ne commence que de 15 septembre
alors c'est à ce moment là en
travaillant avec eux en jouant avec eux
parce que je vais quand même continuer à
jouer je verrai si les rapports sont
exactement les mêmes
non mais je parlais de l'extérieur parce
que vous êtes maintenant un haut
fonctionnaire en même temps qu'un
comédien
je ne pense pas non je crois pas que les
j'ai reçu six ou sept cents lettres de
félicitations auxquelles j'ai tout
répondu bien sûr
et la plupart commencé par uche nous
avons eu peur mais comme aucune ne me
disaient de pourquoi j'en suis toujours
au même point
les noms ont été publiés dans la presse
il n'y aura qu'à consulter les journaux
de cette époque là alors monsieur toujas
d'abord est ce que vous êtes
administrateur général de la
comédie-française où est-ce que vous
jouez le rôle de l'administrateur
général and honour je suis
administrateur parce que je joue et je
pense que dans surtout dans une troupe
de comédiens on s'apercevrait vite des
subterfuges et on ne me ferait plus
aucun crédit
je suis administrateur et je pense bien
l'être
à plein temps d'abord et ensuite avec
toutes les responsabilités que ce poste
alors impose justement les
responsabilités vous avez été dans votre
bureau
déjà voyagé sur votre table de travail à
les programmes pour les premiers
prochains 18 mois qui ont été établies
par votre prédécesseur monsieur pierre
dux ça ça ça vous empêche d'avoir
certaines initiatives au moins pendant
un an et demi on va demander à être
trois ans monsieur chaoui bien sûr si ça
me laissera assez peu de temps pour
pouvoir imposer moi même ce que je
souhaite faire avec la comédie française
mais vous savez aujourd'hui dans tout
théâtre une programmation se fait très
en avance il faut engager les metteurs
en scène les décorateurs très longtemps
avant même que les spectacles commencent
à être répétée donc il était assez
normal assez logique que la
programmation soit faite
lorsque je prenais mes fonctions mais la
difficulté réside dans le fait que c'est
une année tout à fait particulière
puisque nous célébrons le tricentenaire
de la commune française et que pierre
dux ayant souhaité montrer un éventail
le plus large possible de notre
répertoire géant 40 spectacles à peu
près à gérer et à mener à bon port
alors vous avez deux missions
essentielles maintenir le répertoire la
comédie française le fait généralement
fort bien et pas seulement à paris mais
dans les festivals en province et
surtout à l'étranger mais aussi assurer
des créations et là c'était plus faible
ces dernières années je suis un peu
frappé effectivement de voir que la
comédie française depuis une dizaine
d'années obtenu 6 pris de mise en scène
elle est donc pourrait-on dire
exactement moderne et malgré tout nous
restons un théâtre qui est un peu
particulier un peu à part il faut que la
comédie française soit à part mais c'est
à dire qu'elle soit au sommet au plus
haut je crois personnellement que la
comédie française doit être dans la
mouvance du théâtre actuel et pour
l'être il est évident qu'elle ne peut
pas séparer la représentation du
répertoire et en même temps la création
oublier que pendant des siècles nous
avons créé ce qui est le classique
aujourd'hui que ce soit marivaux beau
marché victor hugo avec jean qui était
vivant au jour de la libération examen
aujourd'hui faut attendre d'être mort
quand on est auteur dramatique pour être
représentés chez vous c'est pas tout à
fait pas tout à fait puisque le
4 qu'on a pu appeler d'avant garde des
années 50 que ce soit le théâtre de
beckett le théâtre de ionesco finalement
est rentré dans le répertoire mais il
est rentré vingt ans après ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que ce soit immédiat que
nous puissions créer des auteurs qui
sont un jour des auteurs du répertoire
et comment le savoir
je pense qu'il faut la prendre des
risques et c'est ce que je souhaiterais
faire il ya quelques risques apprendre à
mettre cet instrument extraordinaire
qu'est la comédie française et surtout
la troupe des comédiens français au
service de d'auteur nouveau même de tout
jeunes auteurs la troupe parlons-en est
ce que vous avez envie d'augmenter vos
effectifs géant bien sûr je souhaiterais
augmenter les effectifs puisque ça nous
permettrait de pouvoir jouer sur deux ou
trois salles comme nous le souhaiterions
mais il faut avant tout une troupe
extrêmement cohérente tous les emplois
soient représentés ce que je
souhaiterais aussi c'est que rage de
grands acteurs qui sont à l'extérieur
souhaitent rentrer à la comédie
française le deux grands metteurs en
scène
il me semble que mon mandat sera réussie
et je serais heureux enfin
administrateurs heureux si tant est
qu'on puisse en trouver
s'il en a le sourire cache parfois
l'inquiétude
je serai donc heureux si un jour je
trouvais sur ma table de travail des
demandes d'engagement émanant de grands
comédiens car il ya des emplois qui ne
sont pas pourvus les patriarches y en a
plus beaucoup
est-ce que vous avez par exemple
quelqu'un qui est capable de jouer les
migrants charles aznavour est peut-être
aurait-il un jour venait mais attention
je ne m'engagerai pas pour un spectacle
qu'il faudra signer un contrat de
pensionnaires c'est à dire au moins un
an
alors est-ce que
c'est à la comédie française oui on n'a
pas la chance de pouvoir le faire
ailleurs
et je pense que le fait qu'il y ait ce
mélange
cette proximité du répertoire classique
et des pièces tout très contemporaine
est ce qu'il ya de plus vivants aux
côtés âtre en tout cas la troupe c'est
essentiel vous savez sacha guitry disait
une phrase très amusante à propos de
versailles
il disait lorsque louis xiv construisait
à versailles il mettait notre argent de
côté
eh bien lorsque louis xiv fondé la
comédie française il faisait la chose
essentielle pour le théâtre c'est à dire
une troupe une troupe c'est je crois
primordial grâce à une troupe
on peut d'abord écrire pour une troupe
je pourrais soutenir presque le paradoxe
qu'une troupe précède un certain
répertoire des auteurs écrivent pour une
troupe bon bain voici deux bonnes
nouvelles que vous avez en primeur
d'abord les auteurs dramatiques
contemporain y vivent seront mieux servi
mieux représentés ensuite charles
aznavour n'exclut pas la possibilité
d'entrer un jour à la comédie française
mais vous savez il ya un précédent en
maurice-chevalier il ya fait un crochet
je crois que j'enregistrais jouer une
pièce en tout cas ce qui est
extraordinaire
c'était que j'ai vu d'ailleurs c'était
la rentrée de raimu et la rentrée prévue
finalement on n'est pas obligé de passer
par le conservatoire national d'art
dramatique a maintenant un sujet qui est
un sujet grave et le docteur perron
autret que je vous présente maintenant
prendre lourd de responsabilités puisque
à l'angoissent le beaucoup d'entre nous
connaissent de la mort
il ajoute la peur d'être enterré vivant
dans un livre qui s'intitule très
explicitement les enterrer vivants vous
êtes là représentants du corps médical
donc il s'agit pas d'une compilation
fantaisistes ou partez d'une statistique
un peu effrayante mais
limitez 4% d'enterrer vivant chez les
américaines chez les les soldats
américains chez les soldats américains
et chez les civils américains car il ya
eu aussi le transfert d'un cimetière à
fort en dalkeith un cimetière civil qui
date de 1928 environs où on avait trouvé
environ 4% de traces suspectes à
l'intérieur des circuits lors du
transfert
et puis et puis vous vous appuyez aussi
sur des confidences de fossoyeur en a vu
beaucoup
oui nous avons été obligés d'en voir un
grand nombre et le professeur louis
claude vincent qui a inventé la
bioélectronique on avait vu également un
grand nombre à l'époque où il avait
présidé à la réalisation des grands
cimetières amérique en europe puisqu'il
a été l'année de l'ingénieur géologue
qui les a construits alors là il ya
quelque chose de troublant si on en
croit ces fossoyeurs lorsqu'il procède à
une exhumation il y a très souvent des
traces à l'intérieur qui semble indiquer
que la personne enterrée a déchiré le
bois avec saison william même plus grave
que les traces le signe le plus frappant
le plus horrifiant c'est que certains
enterrés vivants qui ne sont d'ailleurs
pas automatiquement vivant quand ils le
font mais dans un état de catalepsie
dans un état de mort moyenne se ronge le
bout des doigts jusqu'au poignet et
avalent leur suaire est la preuve qu'il
était vivant quand ils le firent c'est
que l'on retrouve ces éléments digérer
c'est à dire que les sucs gastriques
était réellement sécréter lorsque ces
éléments étaient déglutit bon passons
sur ce détail par trop macabre et venons
en à la responsabilité des scientifiques
car évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
manoeuvres criminel ça n'est pas
volontairement que l'on enterre
quelqu'un de vivant alors il faut donc
en déduire que en dépit de l'avancement
de la science et en dépit des moyens
sophistiqués dont elle dispose
aujourd'hui les signes cliniques de la
mort ne sont pas toujours évidents des
signes cliniques de la mort ne sont pas
toujours évident et ils sont d'autant
plus remis en question à l'heure
actuelle que l'on a des notions de
survie qui ont été mises en lumière par
un médecin qui s'appelle du docteur
raymond moody qui avait écrit un livre
simple ans la vie après la vie
alors si vous voulez examinons les très
succinctement les signes qui sont
d'ailleurs
très connue de tous ceux qui ont eu à
déplorer un décès auprès d'eux l'arrêt
de la respiration avec le fameux petit
miroir qu'on approche de la bouche du
présumé défunt l'arrêt de la respiration
tahsin scientifique l'arrêt du coeur
l'électrocardiogramme plat l'électro
encéphalogramme plat c'est à dire plus
d'émissions dont deux au niveau du
cerveau en général devraient ou auraient
dû suffire à déterminer la mort et ça ne
suffit pas or ça ne suffit pas il existe
aussi depuis longtemps une épreuve qui
est une épreuve de médecine légale en
france qui sans doute la plus efficace
injecter de la fluorescéine dans les
veines et constater un certain temps
après une coloration de la conjonctive
le produit colorant passant dans la
circulation
mais ça ne suffit pas encore car il peut
y avoir un arrêt de la circulation
la preuve je vous le répète a été fait
car certains sujets qui ont eu qu un
électroencéphalogramme plat un
électrocardiogramme plat pendant
plusieurs heures se sont réveillés et
ont pu raconter leur expérience de la
mort sans séquelle apparemment par la
suite
alors qu'est-ce que vous conseillez bien
sûr pour entrer dans le détail il faudra
lire ce livre mais qu'est-ce que vous
conseiller pour que des cas aussi
regrettable aussi dramatique puisse être
évité il ya un cercueil dont on appris
le brevet récemment mais qui coûte très
cher c'est exact il ya un cercueil qui
est une invention française pas
réellement récente et que dans le brevet
avait été pris par un inventeur qui
avaient été enterrés vivants
ceux ci recueille coûte en effet assez
cher et il n'est pas très répandu en
france par contre il a eu un certain
succès en amérique il permet donc une
survie d'environ 24 heures sous terre et
il est relié à l'extérieur par un
certain nombre de signaux visuels
auditifs et radio qui permettent
d'alerter les populations c'est une
remake de quelque chose qui existait au
siècle passé en bavière en particulier
où il y avait des maisons des morts ou
les pieds des morts était attaché par un
fil et ce fil relié à une clochette dans
la maison du gardien du cimetière
autrement il reste à souhaiter que tous
les membres du corps médical chargé de
délivrer le permis d'inhumer le fasse en
pleine connaissance de cause merci
docteur bien c'était notre premier
rendez-vous aujourd'hui il y en aura un
dès demain j'espère que vous le suivrez
aussi merci à demain
[Musique]